I hope everybody had a good Memorial Day weekend.
Corona virus in popular culture and in the
national dialog is no longer primarily a medical
event over the long weekend.
That shift has been completed and what Corona
virus now is is a culture war.
And this is by necessity because Donald Trump
has failed on corona virus from the standpoint
of medical, as he might say.
And the only way that Donald Trump can plausibly
purport to appear to be winning maybe, maybe,
is to turn this into a culture war.
And he's being assisted in doing that by the
reopened protesters, by the anti-vaxxers,
by the many others who are actively contributing
to the demise of the United States.
The United States being a laughing stock globaly.
The pandemic is a disease and it is a disease
prevalent over a whole country or the world.
That's what we have in Corona virus.
We have a pandemic.
It is a medical situation.
The culture war is a cultural conflict.
It is a conflict between groups, social groups,
typically sometimes economic groups over values.
It is a struggle for the dominance over values
and beliefs and practices.
And notice that the primary discussions of
Corona virus as a medical issue have been
forced into irrelevance by this administration.
It started roughly a month ago when I told
you that Donald Trump is getting away from
press briefings and instead doing these CEO
propaganda events, these pseudo rallies at
warehouses that distribute PPE.
I think he did one last week or the week before
in Pennsylvania.
I think it was.
And to look at this in a different way, to
look at it as a culture war explains a lot
of the nonsense that we're seeing.
Let me give you an example.
Churches pushed into phase one in a number
of different states as one of the first types
of entities that will reopen.
It's indefensible scientifically, but it's
a cultural signal.
It's a way to signal to signal virtue in a
sense.
And that's why so many governors have included
houses of worship in phase one.
They've been under huge pressure to do it.
And this is why Donald Trump is now making
a huge deal out of churches.
And I'm in a deal a little bit later with
the legal aspect of Donald Trump saying he
will force governors to deem churches essential,
but that now is a culture war around Corona
virus, churches and going to church masks.
Masks are now part of the culture war.
You wouldn't have thought of a mask as a political
tool.
Six months ago.
It is strictly political now for a huge portion
of American society.
Medical issues have been relegated to irrelevance.
Discussions of the are not the reproduction
rate of the virus.
They're talking about it in Germany.
Angela Merkel is talking about it in Germany.
As they look to reopen, they talk about it
in New Zealand.
The contagion treatments and vaccines.
These things are being mentioned by Trump
only in the context of continuing to wage
the culture war.
And in fact, even treatment has become an
opportunity to virtue's signal.
Do you blindly follow Trump on hydroxy chloroquine
or do you not?
Regardless of what the science says, this
is by design.
This is the only way that Donald Trump can
sort of continue to justify his presidency,
to justify his reelection, or to even have
a shot at that reelection.
And this is a movement that has turned a medical
incident into a culture war.
The movement, understand, is an amalgamation.
As I wrote on Twitter yesterday of Trump supporters
who just follow Trump no matter what so-called
libertarians who are just focused on the so-called
liberty elements, which I'll discuss a little
bit later today.
Anti-vaxxers and conspiracy theorists there.
This is a Venn diagram.
Those groups overlap, but they have coalesced
perfectly to pervert the handling of the pandemic
as a pandemic, as a medical incident, and
instead have turned it into a culture war.
By the way, why was Donald Trump the one briefing
Americans from day one anyway?
Or Mike Pence or whoever it was because of
the culture war aspect of this?
The way to de-politicize a pandemic is to
do what many countries have done.
You have doctors do the briefings.
Look at how Ebola was handled back in 2014
and some of the outbreak countries in Africa.
Public health officials were the ones communicating
with the public, not incompetent partisans.
But this is a strategy.
It's a concerted effort.
And the Trump administration realizes this
is their only shot.
So they are active.
We escalating the culture war component every
time Trump issues a threat about overriding
governors.
Those are not medical statements.
Those are not constitutional statements.
He actually can't do it legally.
And I'll talk about that in a moment.
These are merely claims from Trump to amp
up the culture war.
And this reminds me more and more over the
cultural battle, over a medical procedure
known as abortion.
And in fact, sometimes it's been mentioned.
Trump has even mentioned there are governors
saying abortion clinics are essential.
But churches are not.
That's red meat, culture war language.
Having Caylee Magnani regularly attack the
press in briefings is another culture war
component.
Make this not about the medical facts, make
it about fake news and perspective and point
of view.
Charlotte Klein gave this example in a really
great piece in Vanity Fair.
Here is Donald Trump's press secretary attempting
to call out a reporter, Jeff Mason from Reuters,
for asking whether it's really safe to go
back to church, making it a personal thing
where you as an individual don't like religion.
Take a look at this.
Strongly encourage every governor to allow
their church a serial town.
And boy, it's interesting to be in a room
that desperately wants to seem to see these
churches and houses of worship.
President.
I'm go back.
The question that we're asking you.
I would like to ask the president and Dr.
Burke.
Is it safe?
And if it's not safe, is the president trying
to heard that?
Dr. Burke, the people should wait.
Jack, it is safe to reopen your churches if
you do so in accordance with the guidelines
which are laid out.
So the reporter is asking about the safety
of reopening from a medical perspective.
And Cayley makes it about, wow, look at these
left this loony liberal atheist reporters
who are against religion and the church component
is particularly transparent with Donald Trump.
Because Donald Trump has always been faking
his supposed religiosity.
He's never been religious.
He never went to church.
He was never against abortion.
At 68 years old, he decided to run for president.
Suddenly, the Bible is his favorite book.
He had an awakening on abortion because he
met a kid he liked where he learned the mom
thought about getting abortion 20 years prior
or however old the kid was.
But when he was asked what passages of the
Bible do you like, he said, That's personal.
I'm not going to talk about that.
The two Corinthians fiasco autographing Bibles
for people, not exactly showing deference
to the sacred texts.
He was asked, are you an older or a New Testament
guy?
Is both equally.
He doesn't care to know anything about religion.
Religion is merely the perfect tool to get
people who would never otherwise have voted
for Donald Trump voting for him despite his
moral failings.
And now it is a huge part of amplifying the
culture war, religious versus non-religious,
libertarian vs., you know, everybody else
when religion would ideally have no place
in a presidential election or in figuring
out what to do about Corona virus.
OK, so they're fighting this as a, quote,
culture war.
What's the damage done by that?
That's really the important question.
The damage done by fighting this as a culture
war is that it keeps people more divided than
they actually need to be.
The anti-vax or Bill Gates conspiracy, people
are emboldened by this culture war.
They'd be mostly on the sidelines if it weren't
for the amplification of the culture war.
The more people are that are angry and divided
about something as empirically definable as
a virus.
We know what the virus is.
OK, we don't know the exact reproduction rate.
There are question marks, of course, how much
contagion is really happening from surfaces.
OK, but this is an empirically knowable event.
The Corona virus, they have figured out a
way to get away from the empirical questions
and get to these culture war type questions.
And the reason that they don't want the serious
conversations happening, hey, how do we reasonably
balanced the economy and public health?
It's a great question.
There's a range of opinions on the left and
right.
They don't want real conversations happening
between left and right on those on those issues,
because they will inevitably be conversations
that lead to the realization that Trump has
failed from day one.
Trump has to make this a cultural war.
We can hope for that.
The success he's having making this a culture
war is premature, that ultimately, eventually
the facts on the ground will win out.
But that depends on us.
That doesn't depend on him.
We know what the strategy is.